pour les seizièmes de finale résumé de
la journée apple en direct sur le court
central la guerre du feu s'est déclaré
en soit paris et londres la france
maintient sa décision de suspendre les
importations de viande bovine en
provenance de grande-bretagne motif la
maladie de la vache folle débuts
difficiles d'un sommet ardues entre
mihai gorbatchev et george bush à
washington au centre des débats le
statut de l'allemagne unifiée dans
l'otan enfin le monde à pleins poumons
pour la troisième journée anti tabac
enquête sur les répercussions chez les
enfants de fumeurs
bonsoir winogradsky doit penser en ce
moment même à tous ses camarades de jeu
le comte boetsch noah forget champions
qui se sont qualifiés pour le troisième
tour à roland garros
il aimerait bien réaliser sans doute le
même exploit mais il aura du mal face à
l'autrichien mystère dominique champeau
briller absolument paul il aura du mal
d'autant qu'il est mené 2 sets à 0 6 2 6
3 et surtout 3 à 1 dans la troisième
manche qui devrait être la manche
décisive car c'est un as muster qui
actuellement est au service donc en
situation à 40,15 de mener jeu et
d'imposer ainsi la puissance de son jeu
sa régularité
et puis sa volonté de gagner car me
stearns mais relève d'un grave accident
de voiture qui l'a tenu immobilisé
pendant un an
il revient sur les courts avec une
véritable boulimie afin de retrouver la
place qui lui est promise parmi les cinq
meilleurs joueurs du monde
le vin et caroline since et jean
philippe guillin vous proposeront un
résumé complet de la journée si le match
entre winogradsky et mystère n'est pas
terminée
l'a3 le diffusera en direct à l'issue du
19/20 les non fumeurs sont désormais six
actifs et si nombreux qu'il faudra
peut-être entrer dans la clandestinité
pour en griller une
cachez-vous or aujourd'hui par
solidarité c'est en effet la troisième
journée mondiale anti tabac pour dégager
l'atmosphère des manifestations étaient
organisées dans le monde entier
il est vrai que le tabac est un fléau
notamment pour les enfants de fumeurs et
les femmes enceintes en quête des deux
côtés du filtre jean marc pitte
le tabac montrait du doigt la cigarette
sataniser les fumeurs ostracisé la
grande croisade des pourfendeurs du vi
en bâtonnets connaît aujourd'hui son
apothéose avec la journée sans tabac
orchestré par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé à force d'être ainsi dénoncer
les industriels du tabac finissent par
se sentir persécuté
il refuse de passer pour des corrupteurs
de la jeunesse et fait passer les
marques on ne déclenche pas l'acte de
fumer alors je ne crois pas que ce soit
en interdisant la publicité que l'on va
régler le problème de l'entrée les
tabacs des jeunes tabac de toute façon
je crois que les jeunes ont besoin de
choses dans leur adolescence et que le
tabac en fait partie ce qu'il faut c'est
leur faire comprendre qu'on peut vivre
sans ces choses
le tabac est il réellement coupable de
tous les maux dont on l'accuse les
chiffres qui suivent laisse peu de place
à sa défense 30 % de tous les cancers et
90% de ceux de la gorge lui doivent tout
la consommation tabagique air s'est
stabilisée ces dernières années mais on
y est on recueille encore aujourd'hui
l'augmentation considérable la
consommation tabagique des années
précédentes et l'eau l'incidence du
cancer consultants france continue
d'augmenter d'environ 2 à 3% par an ce
qui donne en plus graves ceux qui n'ont
pas pu faire le choix entre leur santé
et leur plaisir sont de plus en plus
souvent victimes du tabac les enfants
des mères qui n'ont pas su vaincre leur
accoutumance au moment de leur grossesse
en supporter les conséquences
le tabac est un toxique grave pour
l'enfant parce que ils l'empêchent de
recevoir la fourniture d'énergie normal
ce qui fait que les enfants poussent
moins on sait que les femmes qui fument
on sait qu'elles ont des complications
très particulière est gravissime de
grossesse beaucoup plus souvent que les
femmes qui ne fument pas du tout sa
santé vous bien votre plaisir mesdames
la guerre du boeuf ou plutôt des vaches
oppose désormais londres et paris ce
n'est pas un gag
cette bataille est si sérieuse que la
commission de bruxelles s'en mêle et
c'est la maladie de la vache folle qui a
phone la cee
gouvernement les français inquiets des
conséquences possibles de cette maladie
ont en effet interdit aujourd'hui
l'importation de viande bovine
britannique en france protectionnisme
rétorquent les britanniques et la cee
simple protection répondre les français
claude guaino la mesure française fait
la une des journaux anglais ce matin
sous un titre très sobre independence
rapporte la colère qu'elle a suscité
outre manche
les travaillistes par le même de coup de
poignard tandis que le gouvernement
n'exclut pas des mesures de rétorsion
pour les britanniques la décision
française est avant tout une mesure
protectionniste destiné à favoriser les
éleveurs français
l'enjeu est important la grande-bretagne
réalisant plus de la moitié de ses
exportations de viande bovine avec la
france pour une valeur de plus d'un
milliard et demi de francs par an pour
les éleveurs anglais c'est d'une
catastrophe
la france est le quatrième pays à fermer
ses frontières il s'agit d'un mouvement
d'inquiétude et de panique qui n'a pas
lieu d'être la viande bovine peut être
consommée et il ne faut pas
parce qu'une épidémie s'est développée
dans un lit l'enchantent des marchés
dans le vôtre est en fait il est certain
qu'il ya eu des importations d'origine
anglaise aussi bien en farine de viande
quand bovins vivants et donc on peut
effectivement s'inquiéter mais
s'inquiétait dans une moindre mesure
c'est à dire que les anglais en fait ont
vu une explosion nous nous n'aurons que
des cas sporadiques
en grande bretagne la maladie de la
vache folle qui s'attaque au cerveau a
déjà tué quinze mille bovins les
vétérinaires préconise d'abattre 6
millions de vaches soit la moitié du
cheptel britannique pour venir à bout de
l'épidémie
à l'heure actuelle rien n'indique que la
maladie soit transmissible à l'homme
françois mitterrand en première ligne
depuis quelques jours le président de la
république s'est rendu ce matin à
l'hôpital paul brousse de villejuif à
l'occasion de la 500ème greffe du foie
il a rendu hommage à tous les médecins
et aux chercheurs français et a
réaffirmé son attachement à la
protection sociale
françois mitterrand cet après-midi dans
les grandes écoles il a protesté à sa
manière contre les inégalités reportage
d'eric héros et clubs du sud et social
ça commence par l'école françois
mitterrand a poursuivi aujourd'hui
devant deux mille lycéens et collégiens
d'evry dans l'essonne
la croisade qu'il a entrepris il ya une
semaine en faveur de la justice sociale
le président de la république a rappelé
l'effort fourni par le gouvernement en
faveur des universités 16 milliards de
crédits supplémentaires construction de
1 million 500 mille mètres carrés de
locaux nouveaux créations de postes
d'enseignants mais devant les besoins
sans cesse croissants du pays en
ingénieurs françois mitterrand a demandé
aux grandes écoles de s'ouvrir à croître
considérablement peut-être doubler le
nombre des élèves dans les grandes
écoles polytechnique et les autres
pourquoi sont-elles ainsi fermé comme
s'il s'agissait d'une chasse gardée et
là je passe à toutes les grandes écoles
ou celle qu'on appelle pas grande mais
qui sont utiles qui sont toutes
exagérément restreinte
le président de la république a
également donné des instructions
précises au ministre de l'éducation
lionel jospin pour que les élèves soient
mieux informés à l'avenir sur leur
carrière
il a également suggéré que l'on créé à
la télévision un magazine hebdomadaire
qui donnerait des informations aux
jeunes pour qu'ils décident de leur
avenir pour la troisième fois en
quelques jours françois mitterrand a
donc voulu montrer clairement que c'est
lui et diane nikki impulser l'action du
gouvernement
une façon de signifier qu'il s'intéresse
de près aux préoccupations des gens et à
la réduction des inégalités
quant aux jeunes eux ils ont fini
l'après-midi rock'n'roll c'est la
troisième fois en quatre jours que
françois mitterrand aborde avec force la
politique économique et sociale du pays
déjà mardi le chef de l'état avait
dénoncé à auxerre les inégalités trop
criante à ses yeux
réaction de henri krasucki le président
ne manque pas d'air
réaction de marie recueillis par marie
hélène tichoux ça sert à quelque chose
de montrer qu'on n'est pas contents mais
pour le moment
paroles paroles paroles mes
encouragements de fait par la force des
choses plus énergique dynamique mieux
rassembler pour que ça se traduise par
des actes réels cent croient au père
noël le père noël ce sont les
travailleurs eux-mêmes business monde
henri krasucki appréciera tout de même
j'imagine la démarche de michel rocard
qui a tenu lui à se rendre et ce n'est
sans doute pas un hasard à jean reno
d'oeuf la visite d'une scène de montage
échange de vues avec les syndicats et la
direction
entretien comité d'établissement michel
rocard effectué c'est certain
aujourd'hui une visite très social
reportage michel lemerle dominique
duchateau
le je suis en plein accord avec françois
mitterrand sur les salaires c'est la
déclaration surprise que michel rocard a
fait à sa sortie de flins on avait cru
penser après auxerre que le premier
ministre est l'hôte de l'elysée n'avait
pas exactement les mêmes priorités bien
michel rocard a tenu aujourd'hui a
souligné qu'il avait besoin que le
président françois mitterrand fassent
pression pour que les partenaires
sociaux engagent des négociations au
sujet des bas salaires et c'était un peu
des travaux pratiques qui l'engagé cet
après midi à flins dernier clin d'oeil
michel rocard a quitté renault flins à
bord de la clio application du discours
du chef de l'état application des mots
de michel rocard avec la création
aujourd'hui une association le titre de
cette association moderniser sans
exclure à l'origine de cette création le
professeur bertrand schwartz qui
explique les raisons de son initiative à
véronique auger quelques années la one
embaucher des circuits aujourd'hui en
anglais et bac bac + 2 je ne dis pas que
ce soit pas de temps en temps
indispensable c'est loin de l'être
toujours on en abuse
et c'est pas une fatalité or à la fois
les diplômés en souffrent parce qu'ils
sont souvent mis sur des postes non
qualifiés à la fois les les non diplômés
en souffre parce qu'ils sont plus chauds
mais alors c'est la raison pour laquelle
avec une cinquantaine de personnes
on a voulu montrer que ça existait il ya
des grandes entreprises qui plus en plus
certaines sont là où aujourd'hui il y en
a de plus en plus ce qui se décide à
qualifier leur personnel mais en
changeant l'organisation du travail
d'inégalité encore cet après midi et
demain les députés prépare une nouvelle
loi qui devront mieux protéger les
travailleurs précaires la loi actuelle a
permis de couvrir de nombreux abus
certains intérimaires d'ailleurs ne se
sont pas laissés faire reportage claude
guaino et alain thomas
c'était il ya un peu plus d'un an une
trentaine d'intérimaires employés depuis
deux ans par citroën à aulnay décide de
saisir le ministre du travail et les
prud'hommes
patricia ouvrière de 26 ans est à leur
tête on a gagné sur les rappels de
salaires qu'ils nous devaient depuis
deux ans correspondent à peu près à
treize mille francs et sur des
indemnités des sentiments qu'ils nous
devaient aussi aux contrats illégaux
parce qu'effectivement j'ai eu un
contrat par mois pendant 2 ans et est
illégal il n'égale pas tout à fait la
loi interdit bien sûr d'empiler les
contrats d'intérim mais citroën prétend
l'avoir respecté la loi y passe utile
d'avoir elle est ce qu'elle est pour
l'interpréter c'est à partir de 1986
après les grandes vagues de
licenciements et avec le retour de la
croissance et le boom de l'automobile
que l'intérim fait son entrée chez
citroën comme dans de nombreuses
entreprises
depuis le constructeur emploie en
permanence 3000 intérimaires soit autour
de 10% ses effectifs
c'est la politique de giroud stocks et
c'est la politique d'ajustement
raisonnable de la main d'oeuvre à la
production nous devons peser pour sortir
tous les jeux civilité possibilité de
logique industrielle d'un côté de
l'autre le développement d'un salarié à
deux vitesses ceux qui ont la sécurité
de l'emploi
côtoyant un nombre de plus en plus grand
de travailleurs précaires à 28 ans après
deux ans d'intérim chez citroën patricia
n'a pas été embauché
elle continue de collectionner les
petits boulots depuis trois ans je
tourne avec des contrats d'un mois d'une
semaine deux ans du chômage entre temps
et du chômage entre temps m'ont
personnellement quel souci ça vous pose
at intérimaire ça me pose des soucis de
logement par exemple trouver un logement
alors combien intérimaire c'est
pratiquement impossible une fiche de
paye intérimaire ça aucun poids le
nombre des travailleurs précaires a
doublé en cinq ans ils sont actuellement
un million dans le cas de patricia et
bruno 6 à 7% des salariés
la réforme en discussion au parlement a
pour but de les protéger et d'éviter les
abus mais encore faudra-t-il que la
nouvelle loi même amélioré soit
appliquée
jean marie le pen se dit persécutée il
l'a exprimé aujourd'hui au cours d'une
conférence de presse
et son parti a tenu à lui distrait avec
que cette affiche que vous allez voir
dans toute la france jean marie le pen
qui misent d'ailleurs andré lajoinie
c'est une affiche qu'elle en a déjà
connu avec le parti communiste et sos
racisme lui répond à sa manière avec la
fiche que vous avez vus un peu trop
rapidement que vous revoyez on aime tous
le même pays
avec cette belle marianne métissée au
lendemain de la demande d'inculpation de
jean charles naouri et de quatre autres
personnes par le parquet deux ministres
réagissent mais pas vraiment dans le
même sens d'un côté pierre bérégovoy qui
réaffirme l'estimé et la confiance qu'il
porte à son ancien chef de cabinet jean
charles naouri de l'autre pierre
arpaillange il exclut toute volonté de
revanche de la justice après la loi
d'amnistié
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré albert
ripamonti en question de vengeance
serait pas digne la justice et les
magistrats n'ont pas se venger d'une
manière quelconque
et puis j'ai quand même beaucoup de
dettes d'inquiétude
elle n'est pas nouvelle mais quand
j'entends par exemple dire que l'un
d'aider des personnes d'une des
personnes poursuivies
c est une véritable cible en raison de
ses fonctions antérieures pour la
justice c'est assez c'est assez grossier
comme traduction de sentiments et ça et
on fait fi de cette manière là vraiment
à la présomption d'innocence de toute
personne tout même une inculpation ne me
dati ça ne va pas faire très plaisir une
très jolie ça a écouté la justice n'est
pas là pour faire plaisir ou pour ne pas
faire plaisir
elle doit être à la fois elle doit
sanctionner des infractions qui peuvent
apparaître grade mais elle est là
également pour faire preuve
d'humanité et de générosité c'est le cas
d'un débat au sein du gouvernement sur
l'opportunité d'ouvrir des poursuites et
roddy un débat au sein du gouvernement
c'est beaucoup trop peu au juge de dire
maintenant si le délit d'initié est
constituée ou non pas facile car en
matière de transactions boursières la
frontière entre le licite et l'illicite
est plutôt floue l'idéal serait bien sûr
de recueillir des confidences
mais ça c'est une autre affaire
ouverture aujourd'hui du sommet bouche
gorbatchev avec au centre des
discussions la question allemande
nous ne résoudrons pas tous les
problèmes du monde en quatre jours a
déclaré george bush ce matin en
appréciant mirail berbatov est sûr en
tout cas que sur la question allemande
le sommet sera particulièrement ardue
gilles du jonchay c'est avec les
honneurs au son des trompettes de la
garde militaire et de 21 coups de canon
que mitrale gorbatchev a fait son entrée
ce matin il était un peu plus de 10
heures dans les jardins de la maison
blanche
mais le gorbatchev accueilli à bras
ouverts par george bush n'est plus
vraiment cet homme qui séduisait
washington il ya deux ans et demi dans
son pays les magasins sont vides de
l'arménie aux pays baltes le pouvoir du
kremlin est contesté lui même vient de
subir un nouveau revers avec l'élection
de son ennemi intime
boris eltsine à la présidence du congrès
de russie tout affaibli clé chez lui
gorbatchev reste cependant un partenaire
redoutable et obstiné il en a donné la
preuve hier avant de quitter le canada
où il avait fait escale en martelant de
nouveau son opposition à l'adhésion de
l'allemagne tout entière dans l'otan
comme le veulent les occidentaux s'est
joué là un vieux disque rayé at il dit
alors que nous avons besoin d'une
nouvelle mélodie
la partie sera donc serré entre les deux
présidents qui ont entamé leur entretien
ce matin dans le bureau ovale de la
maison blanche george bush n'ignore pas
que gorbatchev peut retarder l'échéance
de l'unification de l'allemagne
il va tenter de le convaincre une
allemagne dans l'otan est une solution
moins périlleuse pour la sécurité de
l'urss
une allemagne neutre qui pourrait songer
rapidement assuré sa propre défense
grâce au nucléaire
réussira-t-il dans sa démonstration
mieux que françois mitterrand il ya une
semaine
réponse dimanche j'ai le jonchet vient
de faire allusion aux difficultés de
mikhaël gorbatchev qui ont un nom boris
eltsine
si le rival de gorbatchev parvient à
créer ce qu'ils souhaitent une
république
seul empire sera pour le coup éclaté
sylvie levey bourhis helsinn l'homme
partie le visage de lurs risque de
changer radicalement d'ici cent jours
fort de son pouvoir de président de la
fédération de russie il vient de dire
niet au plan de réformes économiques de
gorbatchev préconisant sa propre idée du
changement beaucoup plus radicale et
puis surtout il vient de dire niet à la
prédominance de l'union fédérale si cher
à moscou en proclamant la souveraineté
absolue de sa république en matière de
politique intérieure
en annonçant hier qu'il serait sur le
point de signer des accords bilatéraux
avec les 14 autres républiques de
l'union
voorhees est le signe du même coup
annuler defacto le blocus économique
imposé par le kremlin sur la lituanie
depuis plus de 40 jours pile ils sont
cautionnés les indépendances baltes
caution réciproque puisque le président
lituanien a été l'un des premiers à
féliciter boris elstine après son
élection et que le premier ministre
estonien doit se rendre prochainement à
moscou pour lancer une véritable
coopération économique
sans aller jusqu'à l'indépendance ce
niet de boris elstine vient de définir
dans le dos de gorbatchev une nouvelle
politique pour les républiques
soviétiques
chacune d'entre elles pourra se doter de
ses propres structures internes avant de
consolider dans un second temps l'union
fédérale tools inverse de ce que soit
gorbatchev
mais peut-être le seul compromis
susceptible de stopper la désagrégation
de l'union des républiques socialistes à
l'étranger toujours en algérie plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes sont
descendues certains sont descendus cet
après midi dans les rues d'alger à
l'appel d'un intermède et du front des
forces socialistes
à deux semaines des élections les
manifestants demandaient une vraie
démocratie en scandant des slogans
hostiles au fln l'ex parti unique au
pouvoir le plus dans l'action sur son
côté
les villages de cette manifestation
l'église et du leader ait ahmed et
anthony voix commente les autres
événements qui se sont produits en
france et qui ont été couverts par nos
stations régionales neuf lignes du métro
parisien fermé ou partiellement bloqué
depuis ce matin de grosses perturbations
également sur les lignes a et b du rer
une des motifs de cette grève les
agressions commises envers les agents de
la sécurité du métro notamment la
semaine dernière où on en a recruté une
dizaine la police de châteauroux et la
gendarmerie font le ménage dans le
milieu de la drogue plusieurs
inculpations 40 interpellations c'est la
plus grosse affaire de drogue connue
dans le département de l'indre elle
toucherait 80 personnes 1 900 francs le
quart de gramme d'héroïne les dealers en
quelques mois avait amassé 2 millions de
francs lourd
un projet de loi destiné à réformer
l'actuel système d'indemnisation des
calamités agricoles c'est ce qu'a
proposé en finale ministre de
l'agriculteur de l'agriculture aux
jeunes agriculteurs réunis en congrès à
perpignan un accueil mitigé pour le
ministre qui a pourtant été entendus sur
un point les problèmes d'environnement
pour lesquelles les agriculteurs sont
prêts à se mobiliser
après de multiples pérégrinations dans
le var la tribu cheval debout s'installe
sur un domaine privé de 13 hectares dans
les alpes-maritimes à colombes
elle pourra exercer son activité
favorite l'artisanat et y vivre tout à
loisir comme les indiens d'amérique le
faisait en 1830
dominique champeau viennent de nous
appeler malheureusement winogradsky a
perdu contre l'autrichien thomas ce
mystère pour nous consoler il faut
savoir que cinq français tout de même se
sont qualifiés pour le troisième tour
il s'agit de le compte de bugs de noah
de forger et de champion le résumé de la
journée avec jean-philippe liens et
caroline since le jour le plus long pour
thierry champion il lui a fallu trois
heures et demie de match pour éliminer
l'espagnol juan aguilera en quatre sets
3 6 6 3 6 3 6 2 un match marathon de
fond de court où il fallait tenir les
changes
à ce jeu là le français pour le meilleur
malgré la fatigue je voyais deux balles
à la place d'une guerre at il ensuite
aguilera tête de série numéro 12 éliminé
il reste cinq français en course pour le
troisième tour
trois petits jeux et puis s'en va
l'autrichien anthony chan balayé cet
après-midi par guy forget est très
facile vainqueur en trois sets secs 6 1
6 1 6 1 au prochain tour forget affronte
champions un français au moins disputera
les huitièmes de finale
j'arrive crispé face à lui le yougoslave
ivanisevic toujours aussi décontracté
réussi un fantastique contre-pied
réflexe j'arrive nos marques oracle ou 5
je vends ce match goran ivanisevic
tombeur de becker enchaîne les victoires
5h05 7 et 7 balles de match pour
qu'enfin le hollandais paul harris
élimine l'américain jim bugs
une victoire qui vaut bien une bise au
filet surprise de taille l'espagnole
arantxa sanchez tenante du titre
éliminée par l'argentine mercedes passe
en trois sets
ironie du sort il son salut dans la vie
est partenaire de nous sur les courts
deux manches 7-5 3-6 6-1 le plus beau
match entre la numéro trois mondiale
monica seles et la canadienne helen
kelesi deux heures pleines de suspense
et une victoire difficile pour celle s
en trois sets 4 6 6 4 6 4
voilà sanchez disparaît les étoiles sont
de plus en plus filantes et surtout plus
en plus jeunes exemple jennifer capriati
14 ans et demi c'est le symbole de cette
génération de petits prodiges
la jeune américaine s'est qualifiée cet
après midi sans problème